(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> Jon: YOU KNOW, AFTER 16 --
I HAVE BEEN HERE 16 YEARS, 17
YEARS -- 16 AND A HALF YEARS.
I DON'T KNOW. I'VE SEEN IT ALL.
FINANCIAL CRISIS.
TO A WAR.
TO ANOTHER WAR. TO WAR. TO
ANOTHER --
TO I THINK IT WAS LIKE FIVE
WARS.
THERE'S NOT MUCH THAT CAN GET TO
ME ANYMORE.
SO I THOUGHT.
(LAUGHTER)
HE (BLEEP) KNEW!
HE KNEW THAT THE BALLS WERE
BEING DEFLATED!
BRADY KNEW!
BY THE WAY, THIS ISN'T JUST A
TABLOID SAYING THAT.
THE "WALL STREET JOURNAL"
ALSO --
(LAUGHTER)
THAT'S NOT REAL, ACTUALLY.
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" COVERED IT!
AMONG OBLONG SPORTS EQUIPMENT, A
DEFLATION PROBLEM EMERGES.
THEY REALLY DO TAKE THE FUN OUT
OF EVERYTHING, DON'T THEY?
BY THE WAY, HOW DID DEFLATED
BALLS QUARTERLY
COVER THIS STORY?
OH, THAT'S ODD.
I WOULD HAVE THOUGHT THIS WAS IN
THEIR WHEEL HOUSE.
SO TOM BRADY IN ALL OF
DEFLATEGATE, WELL, IT LOOKS LIKE
HE KNEW THAT THEY WERE
DEFLATING THE BALLS.
WHAT DID TOM ACTUALLY KNOW ABOUT
THIS THING THAT IS ANOTHER WORD
FOR TESTICLES?
>> THE INDEPENDENT REPORT
CONCLUDES IT WAS MORE PROBABLE
THAN NOT THAT BRADY WAS AT LEAST
GENERALLY AWARE TEAM PERSONNEL
WERE DEFLATING FOOTBALLS BEFORE
A CRITICAL PLAYOFF GAME.
>> Jon: GENERALLY AWARE?
MORE PROBABLE THAN NOT?
AFTER THE STORY BROKE, BRADY WAS
TEXTING THE BALL GUY LIKE HE WAS
A LATE NIGHT BOOTY CALL.
WHAT ABOUT THIS?
>> THE WELLS REPORT SINGLES OUT
TWO LONG TIME MEMBERS OF THE
PATRIOTS LOCKER ROOM STAFF AND
SOME OF THE MOST TELLING
EVIDENCE IS A TRAIL OF TEXT
MESSAGES BETWEEN THOSE TWO
LOCKER ROOM ATTENDANTS, ONE OF
THEM CALLING HIMSELF THE
DEFLATOR.
>> Jon: COME ON! HE CALLS
HIMSELF THE DEFLATOR!
ONE OF THE GUYS IN THE LOCKER
ROOM AT THE BEHEST OF
TOM BRADY CALLS HIMSELF
THE DEFLATOR!
WHAT WAS THE OTHER GUY'S
NICKNAME?
JOEY CHEATS AT FOOTBALL?
WILL NONE OF THOMAS BRADY'S
TEAMMATES RISE TO DEFEND THEIR
CHAMPION?
>> WHAT ABOUT ALL THE
FUNDRAISING FOR THE KIDS?
NO ONE EVER WANTS TO EXPAND ON
THAT, FOR THE KIDS, THE CHARITY
EVENTS.
NO, THEY'RE WORRIED ABOUT THE
STORY FOR THE DEFLATEGATE.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Jon: THANK YOU.
GRONK.
FOR REMINDING US THAT THESE
ATHLETES LIVES ARE COMPLEX AND
THAT MUCH OF THE GOOD WORK THESE
ATHLETES DO IN THEIR COMMUNITIES
GOES UNSUNG AND THAT OUR FOCUS
ON THEIR FOIBLES CAN REDUCE
THESE ATHLETES TO
TWO-DIMENSIONAL THICK-SKULLED
CARICATURES.
I'M SORRY. I INTERRUPTED YOU,
THOUGH. YOU WERE SAYING?
>> YOU KNOW, THESE SURE AREN'T
DEFLATING.
THESE ARE ONLY INFLATING.
SO GET READY BECAUSE I'M GOING
TO BE READY.
AND THERE IS ONLY ONE THING YOU
CAN DEFLATE -- THESE NUTS!
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
(LAUGHTER)
>> Jon: YES, THESE NUTS,
INDEED...
(LAUGHTER)
I GOTTA SAY, I LOVE THIS GUY.
BUT BRADY?
NO.
MEET ME AT CAMERA THREE.
TOMMY...
YOU CHEATING (BLEEP).
WHY!
YOU GOT FOUR SUPER BOWL RINGS.
YOU'RE MARRIED TO THE BIGGEST
SUPERMODEL IN THE WORLD!
YOUR FACE -- YOUR BEAUTIFUL
FACE!
IS A WONDER OF SYMMETRY, A
PLATONIC IDEAL OF BEAUTY THAT
CAN SURVIVE EVEN THE STUPIDEST
OF HAIRCUTS!
(LAUGHTER)
WHAT DID YOU WALK IN AND GO,
HOW YOU DOING TODAY, SAL?
GIVE ME THE SOMETHING
ABOUT MARY. YEAH.
AND YET EVEN WITH THESE DOPEY
(BLEEP) HAIRCUTS, YOU'RE STILL
SO HANDSOME  I WOULD (BLEEP)
THE HOLE IN YOUR CHIN.
(APPLAUSE)
SORRY.
I WOULD!
BUT YOU, MY FRIEND, STOOD UP
THERE IN ONE OF AMERICA'S MOST
SACRED PLACES, THE PODIUM ROOM
BEFORE SUPER BOWL WEEK AND YOU
LIED TO US!
>> ARE YOU COMFORTABLE WITHIN
YOURSELF THAT NOBODY ON SUNDAY
ON THE PATRIOTS' SIDE
DID ANYTHING WRONG?
>> I HAVE NO KNOWLEDGE OF
ANYTHING.
I HAVE NO KNOWLEDGE OF ANY --
>> ARE YOU COMFORTABLE THAT
NOBODY DID ANYTHING WRONG?
>> YEAH, I'M VERY COMFORTABLE
SAYING THAT.
>> Jon: WELL, FIRST OF ALL, IT
LOOKS TO ME LIKE YOU'RE HIDING
SOMEONE ELSE'S HEAD UNDERNEATH
YOUR HAT.
(LAUGHTER)
BUT I'M GLAD YOU'RE SO AT EASE
WITH YOUR OWN DEVIOUS
MACHINATIONS.
I CAN'T BELIEVE YOU HAD AS
YOUR FRIEND GRONK SO
ELOQUENTLY PUT IT, THESE
NUTS TO SAY THAT.
I MEAN, WHY STOP AT DEFLATING?
WHY NOT LACE THE BALL ON BOTH
SIDES.
OR [BLEEP] IT, JUST START
Q.B.-ING ON STILTS?
HOW MUCH IS ENOUGH, BRADY? HOW
MUCH IS ENOUGH?
FOR GOD'S SAKES, YOU HAVE IT
ALL!
IF YOU LOOK UP TALENT IN THE
DICTIONARY, GUESS WHOSE PICTURE
COMES UP!
FRED ASTAIRE, THE MAN MOVED LIKE
AN ANGEL.
HE WAS AN ANGEL.
(LAUGHTER)
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT, BRADY?
YOU'RE GOOD, TOO.
THE GREAT ONES DON'T NEED TO
CHEAT.
DID MICHAEL JORDAN CHEAT TO GET
HIS SIX CHAMPIONSHIPS?
NO.
IN FACT, MICHAEL JORDAN DECIDED
TO PLAY A SPORT HE SUCKED AT
JUST TO GIVE OTHER PEOPLE
A CHANCE TO WIN A CHAMPIONSHIP.
HAND ME THAT BAT, JORDAN SAID,
I'M SURE I CAN FIGURE OUT HOW IT
WORKS, AS HE GOT ON A BUS TO
BIRMINGHAM.
TOM, IF YOU COULDN'T SHOW SOME
INTEGRITY FOR YOURSELF AND THE
CHILDREN WHO WORSHIP YOU, AT
LEAST SHOW PRIDE IN YOUR TEAM.
YOU'RE A PATRIOT, TOM BRADY, A
TEAM NAMED AFTER THIS COUNTRY'S
MOST CHERISHED POST-9/11
LEGISLATIVE SURVEILLANCE ACT.
(LAUGHTER)
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
LET ME JUST SAY THIS -- FROM NOW
ON, WE AS A COUNTRY ARE GOING TO
BE WATCHING YOUR BALLS LIKE A
HAWK.
AND NOT JUST THOSE BALLS --
THOSE NUTS AS WELL.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
AND BY THE WAY...
IF YOU THINK I WOULDN'T CHASTISE
YOU IF YOU HAD COMMITTED THESE
ACTS WHILE IN MY TEAM IN A
NEW YORK GIANTS UNIFORM, IF YOU
THINK I WOULDN'T CHASTISE YOU
FOR THAT, THAT WOULD BE CORRECT.